because what you're really saying is
that black people can't achieve that
that black people are not smart enough
that there's no way we could close the
gap on our own so we need your help to
lower the standards for us
and that's the last thing we need
[Music]
what's up everybody
guess what i'm still here that's right
right here on this rooftop for 100 days
on the south side of chicago on the
block that has notoriously been called o
block oh after a young man named od
perry who was shot and killed
the gangs picked up the name and started
calling it oh block i decided i'm gonna
keep the o but we're gonna turn it into
opportunity block so i'm on this roof in
this tent for 100 days to bring about
the awareness and the attention to the
violence that we experience every single
day in chicago but also to build a
community center to help transform the
lives of people
every day i wake up with a thought an
idea
a solution and i'm grateful because fox
gives me the opportunity to talk about
those things on these rooftop
revelations we call so shout out to fox
and thank you so very much
i woke up with a thought and i've been
thinking about it all day
close to chicago there's a suburb called
oak park
and in oak park they decided
to
get rid of
the
[Music]
academic achievement classes
they decided to get rid of the
honorary honor uh honor classes
in order
that they get they said
close the gap
between black students
and white students
their idea of closing the gap is
lowering the standard
and thus they say equalling the playing
field
but i want to tell you right now
i think that is
insane
because what you're really saying is
that black people can't achieve that
that black people are not smart enough
that there's no way we could close the
gap on our own so we need your help to
lower the standards for us
and that's the last thing we need
we need to make sure
that we have
education that sets the standard
for all of us to meet
so what do we need to do invest in
education at early ages in early stages
we need to make sure that our children
are learning
the things that all kids are learning
we need to make sure that's the reason
why matter of fact i promote school
choice because i really do believe that
sometimes
the public school system is failing our
children
and we as parents should have a choice
to choose for our kids the school that
is right for our kids not because
they're assigned to a neighborhood
and not because they're assigned to a
certain zip code and even though that
school may be low performing your child
still has to go there
no absolutely not
we should have the right as parents
to choose the right schools for our
children
and the last thing we need is for you to
lower our standards
no
we need to meet the standards we need to
achieve like everybody else
and together
we can do that
by making sure that our children are
accountable
just like all children are accountable
that's just my rooftop revelations
that's what i think
until tomorrow
peace
you